a five-year case came to an end for
Iranian diplomat asadola assadi the 49
year old was greeted by senior
government officials on his return to
Tehran on Friday
he was released as part of a prisoner
swap with Belgium
the arrest warrant issued by the
government of Belgium and his arrest in
Germany and the stripping away of his
diplomatic status by the Austrian
government all these moves were against
International laws and conventions
was arrested in 2018 in Germany that's
where officials accused him of a plan to
carry out an attack on an event hosted
by an Iranian opposition group in Paris
but he was extradited to Belgium instead
of Austria where he was based as a
diplomat in 2021 a Belgian Court
convicted and sentenced him to 20 years
the Iranian opposition group at the
heart of the case which is designated as
a terrorist organization in Iran
released the statement condemning the
prisoner swap calling it a shameful
Ransom to terrorism and hostage taking
Iranian officials say asadi was being
used at a time of heightened tensions
with the United States the arrest of
Iranian Diplomat Assad he was uh was a
move aimed at creating crisis between
Iran and Europe because it just happened
after the United States pulled out of
the jcpoa and and Iran's former
president Rouhani was visiting uh Europe
four years after asadi's arrest Iran
detained this man 42 year old Belgian
citizen Olivier Van de Castile in Tehran
on Espionage charges Belgian officials
demanded his release and on Friday the
Prime Minister of Belgium maintained Van
de Castile was wrongfully accused
Olivier spent 455 days in prison in
Tehran in unbelievable conditions
innocent all of ivanda castille's return
to Belgium as a relief a relief for his
family friends and colleagues
the prisoner swap was mediated by the
Gulf State of Oman
the news of the prisoner exchange came
from the Omani foreign Ministry just
days before the Sultan of Oman hyphen
bintarik is due to arrive in Iran on his
first official visit on Sunday and
Friday's announcement will likely be
seen as yet another example of the
important role a mom plays in mediating
difficult issues between Iran and
Western powers
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran